hey guys what's up welcome to another
episode of wrists of fury I'm Kelsey
cook and today I'm so excited because I
get to destroy the one and only Josh
wolf hi hi thank you for having me
I feel opponents should shake yeah oh
very good sportsmanship right out the
gate I want you to know that I've played
foosball three times in my life oh my
god okay I played in a bar once and this
Center one came like that close and I
was like I'm playing pool yeah yes I'm
like nut PTSD yeah well this is why
they've got the little caps now so
you're good okay um so I always thought
there was a four-person game so are we
supposed to play with all four or you
just pick two to play with oh wow so
this is all four rods on you they're
singles and there's doubles huh so if
you look at my trophy display here what
is that real no those real trophies
they're my trophies is there like a
foosball League do they give trophies
yeah there's a whole there's a foosball
Hall of Fame my mom is in the foosball
Hall of Fame I'm not sure that I'd be
bragging about that yeah this is real
man um you have one of my trophies over
there I see oh yes your bomb yeah I
appreciate that
oh yeah that's where I'm the champ so
anytime anyone wants to step up and you
know what I got for Hanukkah is a
menorah bomb oh my god is that although
are you go you light all eight and then
you just yeah so anytime you want to
come over and play my game I should have
gotten super high and played this I
thought you were going to here's what I
did is I took an edible on the way over
so I figured the first game I'll be
pretty sober but by the time the
handicaps start to happen yeah I'm I
will be handicapped
I'm so [ __ ] excited so that's the
thing this is gonna be the best game
ever all right you've got the the balls
on your side yep yep there you go oh
these are heavy yeah like a ping-pong
ball no it's real [ __ ] this is like the
good stuff thank you to warrior for this
amazing table they don't [ __ ] around you
now know how good you are right you have
you have an idea of how good I am
hold on yeah okay let me back Wow so you
have an idea about how
trauma three so if you were gonna guess
yeah how long it'll take you to beat me
in the first game or this is mine how
long do you think well even just that
situation you're just grabbing an on rod
oh well let me ask you that would you
consider this to be the lefty or the
right II side of the table it doesn't
work like that cuz it's the same on both
sides there right my left hand right but
that's for everybody
same in my left hand just below your hi
v-- variable has really started to kick
in a little bit so basically if you're
left-handed in your playing foosball
it's easier for you to make these shots
back here yeah but if you're
right-handed easier with your for it
which two should I start holding so
you're gonna start going to give you the
ball start a little helpful thing for
you yeah you are gonna be here okay cuz
you're gonna be playing with it on your
v bar you're gonna try to pass it to
your your 3 bar so I wanna do this
yes there you go so go ahead and put the
ball here okay okay so you like that and
that way you can move it oh there's no
way I'll move it down the side it's
probably mostly back it's just you know
side to side people move it side to side
oh yeah round one regulation but let's
make a bet everybody how long is this
first game last should we put should put
3 minutes on clock just three minutes
count getting the ball starting over or
three minutes of game time
three minutes everything I think yeah I
think you're overshooting it but here we
go so we're gonna play standard game
first person to five all right all right
yeah go for it wait wait wait so this is
my goalie yes okay so my goalies over
here I tried I couldn't even do it I
almost caught myself
that was crazy I'm gonna try to cheat
yeah that was quick calm down this is
left hand like I can't I don't I can't
brush my teeth lefty so this is a
problem so I'm you got it you're gonna
just get better and better as this game
goes on hey look at that
alright
look at you blocked I was setting
everything up I okay let's go I tried to
cheat yeah III listen I have I meet you
in a minute fifteen yeah all right
by the way those those wrist shots were
crisp thank you yeah [ __ ] crisp like
iceberg lettuce man by the way who have
you beat quicker than in a minute in 15
seconds
well we haven't timed it like that but I
do think that I beat you faster than
anybody we've had on the show so far
okay so I'm gonna take that as a
compliment okay cuz I mean that's your
choice that makes me the best the best
at being the worst
yes yes okay okay yeah all right so this
next game how do we make it fairer for
me round two handicapped play so we're
gonna do some things to make it easier
for you to win in the second round
are you gonna leave and you take okay so
for this whole second game you get to
start with it right on your forward so
it's more like a direct shot for you
make it a little bit easier okay my
handicap is oh god I have to go full
pirate Josh Oh pirate full pirate by the
Mimi's voice - [ __ ] really yeah you
can't go hat right full pirate means out
of her you got a and and if you don't if
you score and you're not in the pirate
voice it doesn't count okay okay
full pirate it's gonna be pirate voice
on one leg as if I have a peg leg only
one hand like I have a hook hand and I
start here one I eyepatch and I start
here and you start there all right Josh
if you don't beat me I feel like I will
I will beat my minute in 15 second time
that's the only thing I can guarantee is
that it will last longer than maybe in
15 seconds oh my goodness this is my
name
yeah you guys bought a child's pirate
costume FYI are you going to attempt to
spin one of those with the hook oh he
scored with a hook I honestly would have
if I score with a hook I went
automatically alright it's definitely
I'm starting a little high it's not even
noon you're dressed like a boy okay you
are gonna start it here I have to play
on one foot all right okay oh my god
this is okay I'm ready oh my can't do
that no spinning I didn't even come
close to scoring everybody
oh she's moved no you're grabbing it
with your hand not the hook yeah I can't
even get to the she's gonna she's about
to score on me one leg how do you I
can't do a pirate accent yard
all right take your point matey yep okay
did you get the ball yes
where does it start there yeah hold on
okay how about how come I have a feeling
you get score right from there hey yo
okay put it there front of there like
hot one get it oh my god my legs falling
asleep you can switch the back of you
yes [ __ ] pirate accent yeah that was a
little by the way that was like almost
Fort Lauderdale oh are you into a false
sense you know like a lot of people in
Fort Lauderdale are pirates though yeah
Oh ice I stopped something not on
purpose yes how many hours do you think
of foosball have you played I've been
playing since I was literally like 2
years old standing on a stool to see the
top of the table that's so that's pretty
great my mom's considered like the
historian of the sport she wrote the
world table soccer Almanac
did you know my Woody Harrelson and yes
I did call it a sport [ __ ] you
also called the table soccer it's
technically table soccer Marie coming
out soon I tell this is a good time to
get on the food sports train what's the
documentary called oh they better come
up with something good
you wanted me my god I really feel like
maybe we can all get together and pitch
it out a little bit uh do you like the
name of this show wrist of fury I love
the name of this show thank you wrists
of fury that was also my nickname in
high school I don't write ha ha ha let's
be honest what did you think was gonna
happen when you went pirate you knew
you'd still beat me after the first game
you saw how bad I was
yeah but I thought if I thought I was
gonna struggle more you know what's
interesting about the way you describe
that is she didn't say anything about
how well I do she was really just like I
felt I could still do okay oh yeah yeah
you honestly
been waiting in the parking I was
basically I was I was although I blocked
one not with this guy but I think with
this guy and then I cheated twice and
scored
I've seen people cheat so far on this
but you you take the cheating to another
blatant I just moved your guy and you
just throw it yeah you there's not even
that you threw it once I missed yeah
which is pretty bad pretty bad it's on
the can't help you so we even talk about
my mom a Hall of Fame you get to have a
little mini coaching session with my mom
right now I'm there FaceTime her oh and
she'll give you some pointers to maybe
try and help you out for this third
round expert advice hi okay this is Josh
okay so give Josh some coaching tips to
make that noise
yes yeah feel like that's good grip the
palm roll oh that's looking better I
have one more question now that you know
I I grew up with three older brothers so
to me psychological warfare is really
important when you're competing against
people who are better than you can you
give me some good dirt on her that Ike
so I can talk some good [ __ ] during the
game round three son dad
what happens in the third round so we
play two ball which means that we're
gonna play with two balls at a time yes
what she said but I'm there and then you
have to score both in order to get a
point so if I score want to use for one
it's a wash and so the first person of
three wins what are the odds do you
think that I score one hand you score
one very long yeah
so this is like winner-takes-all by the
way I beat you two games so far but if
you beat me in this it's everything but
if you lose yeah you have to take a bong
rip
but with old weed in it that's some
nasty old burnt up [ __ ] then you got a
is that any problem for you that's still
a prize for you
yeah that's happens if that's what
happens if I lose yeah okay so you're
saying get the bomb bong prepped get the
bong prep okay ready 1 2 3 oh do you
don't have to stick with the same ball
right no you're both of them ah [ __ ]
oh I all scored where are you wait wait
wait wait wait wait one wait wait wait
wake up hey one more come on you get one
you get one okay I get to start with
both of them okay oh I will
[Applause]
but you got a little treat waiting for
you there ready are you usually just
like stoned all day all night um you
know it depends on the day okay I'm
usually high all day yeah
so this is really just as part of your
day this is part of a normal Monday are
you a drinker
yeah or you just get some on the warrior
let me tell you something that once I
tell you it you'll never forget this
about me I if I had run out of like
chaser or anything I would take shots of
gin and chase it with deli meat I can't
imagine going to a bar me like hey can I
get two shots of gin your hand back
there I like a thin slice you know I
don't want a chunky just like a thin ham
mm-hmm look at that happy Monday yeah I
feel like I'm not sure if that works
hold on the old I don't even know
anything about can you get anything from
the little old not getting it work oh it
was my way of you know I don't want to
leave any you know what I mean warrior
I'm so glad you came on the show thank
you I'm so happy to be here oh man
you're the best Josh wolf ever baked go
go follow Josh online where can people
find you at Josh wolf comedy perfect you
can follow me at Kelsey Creek comedy on
Instagram
Kelsey cook on Twitter else cook calm
and yeah
thank you guys for watching another
episode of risk of fury
be sure to pick up your official Larisa
fury shirt they are buttery soft they
feel like dolphin skin they're amazing
be sure to LIKE and subscribe to the all
things comedy channel and you can get
the shirts at the link below
free shipping